foreign
[Music]
Mario
good [__] bread
um
I said let's get after it and I meant it
your questions and comments I'm Chris
are we ever going to get any of ours in
there I don't know man we're trying
though I can tell I know people are
trying scribing and following here at
the Chris Cuomo project look the beauty
of it is I do this not just to you but
for you and about you so what do you
think what do you like what do you not
like what do you agree with disagree
with let's get after it you already said
that your Guido idiot
[Music]
the chomo project
I I still can't get over that I who was
it was it pessy that spotted that yeah
it was yeah so I was like [__] that
was a beautiful [__] spot
[Music]
okay have this more interested in some
YouTube comments we have a lot from the
audience so here we go hang on hey hey
hang on you forgot to eat the third
stinger
from your interview with Adam Carolla uh
Donald Navy goat 23 writes I've watched
Tucker for years he's the only person on
Fox who defended you after you're firing
go back and watch the tape it's true he
did we played it on the show he goes I
don't like Chris Cuomo but this is a
really for standing up for his brother
the most human thing he's ever done
that's what you're gonna fire him for I
remember watching that to be fair though
Tucker did also [__] rip of course
dude a lot
that's not true
I know he did I saw it Hannity was
supportive as well
okay so two people you know what he
meant and if I were you uh I would call
first of all
nobody came after me as much as Tucker
Carlson did
agreed he got to him he got him bro you
could tell he's shell-shocked it got to
him that's why they all hate this guy
that's why the mere mention yes makes
them all [__] okay now do I think he
did it gratuitously absolutely did he do
it because it worked with uh the people
who follow him yeah no hey Chris Chris
Chris before you would you don't need an
earpiece for the show bud you know
your producer's on camera wow so you
could just cut to the producer telling
you stuff wow is he having he doesn't
want to wear headphones he wants to be
cool because of his hair you're right oh
my God you're right he's the one handful
because I don't want that [__] messing
on my and if I wear headphones I'm gonna
look like an amateur hour bro I'm gonna
look like uh some kind of [__] dork
or something Rogan wears headphones he's
the biggest podcast on the planet
you don't understand these are fresh
plugs and if I put the headphones over
them they're gonna stab my scalp extend
them like a baby yeah the doctor said
don't put nothing on my head
do I think he says and does most things
I've been sleeping sitting up like The
Elephant Man so I don't even touch my
scalp to the bed
yeah I'm a human being I'm not Fredo
um do I think that if I were to see him
in person especially right now I would
knock him the [__] out
uh you you think you think you would
that's right yeah in person especially
right now he would talk to me the way he
talks about me absolutely not
he's doing the tough guys
he's doing the Italian guy in any
hypothetical situation
he's doing a bit Chris I would say to
your face you want to know why you might
kick my ass you probably would but here
nah maybe not you know what let me not
say that you might not kick my ass but
if you did if you hit me first curse
over words I would sue you and that's
how that will go you idiot no no no I
would can I I would have you arrested
yeah then I would sue you person
especially right now he would talk to me
the way he talks about me absolutely not
why okay does that matter to you I don't
know should but maybe not
you won't say it on my face is that's a
threat you're saying under threats of
violence people lie to you and don't
tell you the truth because you're a
meathead is what you're saying yeah and
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt
let's say it's not a threat it's still
like this I I hate this argument people
always make when if you have a show
let's say right like and e-fags are
always like this right like you if I
criticize somebody or you criticize
somebody that we don't necessarily have
like beef with but it gets back to them
and then it's like oh you wouldn't say
that [__] to my like if I saw you
somewhere in person you wouldn't just
and I'd be like yeah because I don't run
up to people immediately and and start
screaming out all my minor gripes with
them that's usually not what I do
especially if I don't hate you so the
whole argument of you wouldn't say that
to my face it's like well I would if you
pressed me to say it but like if you're
saying I wouldn't back up what I'm
saying but he's trying to imply like
yeah I'm sure if I ran into me to be
polite yeah I'm polite to people I don't
like either I'm not trying to have m
work moments every moment of my life you
know Ray wombat says Tucker Tucker needs
to pull up is what Cuomo's saying he
needs to pull up Eric July is telling
people to do that I know I saw was it
dick Masters and he said to pull up yeah
you need to pull up yeah
what does that mean man
you want to fight different Masterson
because he's very frail I don't think
he'll fight they were defending uh
defending me they don't even know me
defending me as a way of beating up on
CNN and showing we have a story about
you that we can't tell and it bothers me
and how uh this is some manifest you
know which one and it really bothers me
because right now is the perfect time
that would completely undercut its
entire argument I'm not going to because
we keep our word but a station of what
the left does that allows them to beat
up the left you know I mean I don't see
that as uh as Angelic or as
compassionate as you do
um but look
I'm not in the beef business by the way
Angelic or compassionate the guy only
said hey he stood up for you you made
everything else up in your head Bud the
question was that he defended you okay
and I'm not in the animosity business
you're not in the beef business what are
you talking about you pushed plenty of
mRNA vaccines guys a field guy remember
his fake 100 pound dumbbell that he that
he just tricep that's right the 100
pounds people give me [__] and come at
me all the time I think they do it
because it works for them I think people
write nasty [__] about me and try to
expose me
um what if you're just an [__] Chris
Chris
we have more views on you on [__]
Rumble than you have being someone who's
been Sienna for a decade has on YouTube
Chris what are you talking about we're
punching down right you know that you
know we're punching down right now right
Chris are you aware that that that's
your you're you're not he's his best
video
so if we go to videos and we go to
popular let's go to popular uh eight
months ago boy but that was when he was
on when he had when he was on TV it but
again that was his Bill Maher thing that
he put up but it's not even from his
YouTube it's from that news show that he
had that news Nation so basically his
biggest video that he's done on his own
has Tucker Carlson in the in the in the
title correct
uh his biggest videos are him
interviewing people
uh for example like interviewing uh Adam
or Adam Coral interviewing him Neil
deGrasse Tyson but even with the
neograss Tyson now only at 112. you know
Alec Baldwin uh yeah if you're getting
these kind of guests and you're doing
those kind of numbers it's pretty
pathetic yeah Alec Baldwin uh Tyler
Perry
Jesus Christ these are really bad Chris
Jesus [__] Christ Chris what 44k 35k
drops really fast [__] did I lose it I'm
an idiot sorry sorry I did it to myself
I lost it
there's many ways as they can that are
negative because it's click bait and it
works for them and that's just the yeah
it's putting Chris Cuomo in the thing
really gets us on the outside from the
YouTube comments of people commenting on
the YouTube comments video
Tracy Holt wants to know Chris how would
the House and Senate work with say four
parties in them who would get speaker
Etc what is this who cares why would you
even pick that question out of all the
questions what's the bird this is this
is like sports radio and they go hey
what if the Celtics had Chris Bosh
they don't so why are we having this
conversation right
I hate hypotheticals there's nothing
worse than somebody's like hey could you
imagine right if like you know Joe
Montana and his prime or like you know
Joe Namath who's playing now for like
the Dolphins and you're like no it's
it's because it's not it's not real it's
imagine it's like Michael Jordan played
with LeBron
you're basically Frankie you're
basically Frankie McDonald going imagine
if a car went one billion trillion
trillion gajillion million miles an hour
yeah see what he tweets that [__] hey
you better stop that's like 20 minutes
of certain people's compound show no
brute I might as well talk about what is
true
but you know Jerry Jerry writes hi Chris
I used to work at 1285 Avenue of the
Americas for 10 years Docs
I saw you every day getting bagel and
coffee I told you once I speak Dutch
like your wife no way lol I don't eat
Bagels I was gonna say that's that's I
haven't had a carb since the twin towers
felt bad times
all right the only you know what I never
forget two things the last bagel I had
on 2001 and The Towers falling down what
about so so what about you saying yeah
that's nice yeah how about me nice he uh
he later on in the video I skipped ahead
he gets the voicemails voice messages if
you go to 1412 the last voice message
message it's one of the funniest things
I think I have ever 14 12 okay sounds
like of all the things we've heard from
these listeners who that may or may not
want to call them idiots didn't you you
want to call morons we call them morons
we don't [__] hide it you hide it you
[__] be true I know you're not a bagel
guy I'm not a bagel guy my wife does not
speak Dutch unless she's pulling
something over on me
um but I'm not a bagel fan I wish these
Bagels would go back to where they put
Oh you mean the food so do you think
that some just random Guido yeah they
thought it worked in finance that like
dressed like Chris Cuomo was just
getting his big old coffee every day or
I I think this guy confused him with
another reporter that might have a Dutch
wall I bet you if you look up CNN
reporter with Dutch wife you'll get some
other guy in CNN probably confused him
appreciate you remembering me and I love
meeting and talking to people it really
bothers my kids and friends
um because they think that I take too
much time doing it but I appreciate
buddy this you're not that popular
that's why you do it 1412 you said
well go I guess good let's do a few of
the voicemails what are you doing for it
yeah well there's just a few after I
think too but you know yeah you know
let's do Let's do let's do this one
first
hey Chris it's your number one fan I
just wanted to say tattoo
oh God that was how are they doing with
the war going on are you still they
still making out and stuff
congratulations for reaching 100K
subscribers on YouTube I'm so happy for
you and this is not a real call you to
watch the Chris Como project it's his
wife in the other room something that I
look forward to watching and it's
something that makes my nights
see sounds like she's got a lot of
passion remember remember the people
that we said would vote for Newsom it's
women like this who watch this Chris
Cuomo because he thinks he's buff yeah
and I just hope that your YouTube
channel continues to grow amen yeah
congratulations that's a Cuban
okay bye thank you very much uh I
appreciate your excitement and I hope
that you're right uh and that the reach
and the residence continues because
that's why we're doing it trying to
um be valuable to as many people as
possible
uh in as many ways as possible and
working with you and the team to try to
find that sweet spot of uh what works
and what how it seems because that's the
whole swim in this kid of this and uh
I'm happy that you're happy because
that's the goal is to be of value to
people like you so thank you thank you
for giving me the opportunity and I
thank you for the feedback that was a
nice call you just waltzed into 100.
okay yeah Kevin Nash had to sacrifice
his son to the Illuminati to get 100K
Subs
you got off the lights making sure that
I'm dropping in the nice ones I'm
convinced the one at 14.
okay let's do 14th
I'm convinced it's Andrew calling and do
a good voice
called before and and serenaded our
voicemail account really yeah
I do think it's also instructive that
you note when you put in a nice skull
I'm trying desperately to balance this
out because I don't I'm not trying to
put in only mean calls I'm trying to
because because I got a lot of good
calls can I guess they're mostly mean
calls oh I bet you Chris I bet you I was
thinking Chris puts people up to making
these calls for him but I bet it's this
guy one of the things that this guy has
to fake the stuff
to make Chris feel good yeah I bet that
chick is a friend of this guys right
like I guaranteed he's like a sister in
law or something that he was like hey
could you just like
call this voicemail and say congrats on
you know 100K Subs make up some stupid
name like tattoo
and just call and say that okay
I think you're all watching uh they were
watching
fantasy
and he's like turn the TV down my
sister-in-law is gonna call Chris I got
a work thing to do you have [__]
sisters and all things probably Tatiana
he'll just show you a tattoo yeah
yeah I'm trying to balance it out Chris
but don't worry we got plenty of people
to love you too
people pose questions or challenge your
points of view you were the one who told
me when we started this I don't want to
hear just love I don't know it's true
that's absolutely true and it should I
expected because I'm provocative for
people for whatever reason and two
um I think people are more inclined to
comment on things that they're pissed
about than that they yeah no [__] or
admire literally interested it's
literally a universal truth we've known
for decades there's so many [__]
literally nobody there's a phrase for it
nobody calls the store to tell them the
milk was fresh
think that it's an extreme inclination
all right well here's here's another
nice one
um I really
you know I've been listening to you for
years I really this is the one right
yeah okay here we go you think that with
Donald Trump with the Russia Russia and
all the oh my God is that his brother it
says just keep listening is that his
brother no no no no no no no no no
you're really
Don't Be A Man About It
mostly to your brother
you should really call your brother once
in a while and tell him you're sorry for
trying to outshine him and you know uh
you got fired anyway kind of feel like
you're gonna help me a little bit more
I'm just saying like you know you you
help me behind the scenes you could have
put your neck out there for me on CNN
and now I'm out of your campaigning with
Trump I look like a [__] FANUC thanks
so [__] much yeah so maybe apologize
and make peace with your brother even
Trump was able to do that you want to be
a do you want to be a smaller man than
Trump
I haven't taught you to be a man
he spoke okay this is his brother right
man I'm sorry this is his brother right
it has to be it [__] has to be
more direct it wasn't a coward
um you don't get that impression I hope
you um
stand up one day and be a man and see
what CNN did to you and you know what
and say you know what perhaps I was
being led all right can I be honest with
you if if I got a call like this
it would creep me the [__] out
yeah you know what I mean like this is a
weird parasocial
like this this is either his brother
which I'm convinced now it is or it's
the guy from the end of Talk Radio
isn't that guy dead though
uh no the guy that killed him oh okay
be a man
no shame in your game huh
um what does that mean how is that
applicable how is that applicable to
anything that it was just sad that was
his brother that was his brother that
was his brother No One's Gonna tell me
I'm convincing that was his brother that
sounded like his brother it was it was
so personal
it was so personal
that you should check yourself
um about talking to somebody about what
makes him a man or doesn't make him a
man you literally do that all the time
all you
did what and also [__] you went on
started a voicemail line and said hey
guys
give me get throw it at me both barrels
tell me what you think
you did the worst thing
you did the worst possible thing let me
tell you something if you think it makes
you a man
because you swallow
what they're feeding you in Trump land
about how everything that was done to
him was corrupted that's not what he
said that's not what your brother said
what your brother said was now they're
friends you need to apologize to your
mother or something yeah what your
brother said was be a man is what he
said be a man and admit that the Russia
stuff was [__] which it was it was
you could actually go out there go you
know what the Russian stuff was [__]
we were all [__] gonna deflect and
you're gonna move the [__] uh I'm a
man I do a lot of push-ups okay Chris
the FBI was just out to get him because
they're a lefty agency yeah I've been
doing this 25 years I have I'm part of
the Lefty agency pal I know they used to
call me now I'm out still like my
brother but I used to be in those little
meetings okay
you know I had to bring him a coffee and
[__] but like still like he's a season
those things like a stone cutter where
he's at the bottom like Mr Burns oh God
yeah that's right since Monday since
Monty
never until Trump heard anyone discuss
the FBI as being a lefty outfit
um well because the FBI I will say this
the FBI isn't pretty much a left-wing or
a wife a unit party it's a una party
thing so I will agree that describing as
a lefty Outlet isn't right
but currently right now the the party
that's in power is left and they are
control they are basically controlling
the narratives or they didn't like Trump
and let me tell you you guys are only
worried about what the FBI does uh when
the outcome matches your politics you
weren't upset about what the FBI was
leaking about uh when the race between
DeSantis and Gillum was close and all of
a sudden they started leaking about
Gillum and it helped the santis in the
race everybody that never happened that
never happened nothing the FBI leaked
affected the election here we live here
you [__] [__]
nothing they leaked nothing they leak
affected one [__] vote
as much as Trump's magic wand of sending
the FBI down there for the magical
election irregularities that he was just
lying to you about none of that bothers
you but there were you want me to
apologize I'm going to say this for the
50th time I never apologize even if I'm
wrong I'm an Italian guy my feet are
[__] dog in I don't care what new
facts are happening I don't care what
new facts come out I'm staying right
here I'm gonna stay right here I can't
be wrong
I don't think you watched my coverage
okay
I had problems with impeachment because
if you weren't going to get them with
something that was ugly and obvious
there was going to be political payback
and backlash I set it to shift on my
show early on
check it the dossier I took it for what
the intelligence people were taking it
for just like everybody else
so what you're saying is that they are
correct that they have been lying here
the whole time and they are corrupt but
you're saying look instead of being a
journalist I took it for face value like
everyone else hey I got bosses to please
which I apparently didn't because I'm
not there anymore but that's not the
point okay and I qualified it
every step of the way just like
everybody else who was doing the job
and the idea no you didn't no you didn't
no you didn't we [__] covered you you
[__] liar because they didn't find a
crime you guys come in and you read off
the telephone they did find crimes the
back of that report by Mueller was
filled with a number of things he felt
or his team felt warranted criminal
investigation of anybody else except a
sitting president because of the
Reckoning of the office of legal counsel
so I don't know why you guys keep
repeating this [__] that people feed
to you
um because you're literally repeated the
[__] that the intelligent scenes
that she fed you
crazy yeah because it's got the word
intelligent in it so they should and I
didn't want them to think I was stupid
that's stupid I'm not [__] stupid
God he is a [__] [__] huh I love him
I love I love Cuomo I love that his
brother's back I love that everybody's
back
my favorite Brothers
do I believe that the investigators got
things wrong and overreached and were
overzealous yeah that's on them not on
me for reporting it
no responsibility he's just not none
none no it's it's their job for report I
just reported it Italian men and white
women have that same that Gene
I wasn't wrong you were wrong you took
it wrong but a real journalist wouldn't
just take that at face value Chris
that's why you net you're not a real
he's making it seem like look the
government told me what was happening
and I happily said okay I didn't
question it there's very that's not
journalism you [__] [__] that's
being a puppet of the Democrat Party
whatever Party Republicans do it too
it's the same thing you're being a
[__] puppet of who's in power yeah no
there's he's a lot of these anchors
like that that's an anchor a lot of
these guys that never had to be a
journalist a lot of these guys just were
like like he was a Cuomo he was like a
young good looking guy and they said
stick him in front of the camera and
he's just been reading off a
teleprompter for years but then doing
that makes them think I'm a journalist
yeah like they're out there [__] like
Wolf Blitzer during the Iraq War I don't
think so pal
[__] and Kelsey Jones or whatever the
[__] we were looking at earlier she's
more of a journalist than he is she got
the whole goddamn scoop about the kid in
the Busch Gardens the enclosure she had
to go interview that [__] guy with
the weird nose like the judge from
nothing but trouble
someone said let's just play the [__]
scene from True Romance or just explain
why he's the way he is that's a good
call man I honestly that that really is
that that's exactly am I lying
way way to go out like a G man that
seemed so great well hey that I knew
Como's gonna do the rest of the show I
knew that was gonna [__] happen the
best part of that scene is when they
when the Laughing comes down and then he
just takes that like he starts like he
could just see it in his [__] face
and he takes that one last drag like oh
man the best part of that scene is when
he said oh that's a good part that was a
good part he said like a lot like one or
two times is fine like 80 or 90 times
ancestors that means your
great-grandmother [__] dude it was
wild that's still one of the wildest
scenes ever